مطلب جديد يتصدر اجنده الغاضبين في الشارع
الاسرائيلي ينافس مطلب استعاده المحتجزين
في قطاع غزه اعداد كبيره من الاسرائيليين
يخرجون في تل ابيب وحيفا والقدس للمطالبه
برحيل رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
والذهاب نحو انتخابات مبكره حتى قبل ان
تضع الحرب اوزارها بعض هذه المظاهرات التي
حملت شعار الاسرائيليون يستحقون قياده
افضل شهدت قمعا من قبل الشرطه الاسرائيليه
التي اعتقلت عددا منهم المشهد في الشارع
بدا وكانه انعكاس لحاله تشظ تتصاعد بين
القيادات السياسيه والعسكريه الاسرائيليه
لا سما بعد ما وصف باجتماع عاصف للمجلس
الوزاري المصغر مساء الخميس الماضي الذي
انتهى دون بحث مرحله ما بعد الحرب على غزه
حين فتح وزراء من اليمين المتشدد النار
على رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي هرسي
هاليفي على خلفيه تشكيله فريقا للتحقيق في
احداث السابع من اكتوبر الماضي برئاسه
وزير الامن ورئيس اركان الجيش السابق
شاؤول مفاز ما اثار مشادات حاده دفعت
نتنياهو الى فض الاجتماع الهجوم على
هاليفي جاء وفقا لوزراء كبار بتنسيق من
نتنياهو نفسه المستميت بحسب خصومه
للاحتفاظ بمنصبه مهما كان الثمن اذ اتهمه
بعضهم باطاله الحرب والتضحيه بارواح
الجنود والاسرى من اجل بقائه على راس
السلطه التنفيذيه الهجوم على الجيش ومشهد
التباينات في المواقف والاجندات دفع
169 قائدا عسكريا سابقين لتوجيه رساله الى
هاليفي عبروا فيها عن دعمهم له وذكر
الموقعون على الرساله انهم شاهدوا بحزن
الجبهه التي فتحها الوزراء لهزيمه الجيش
ورئيس اركانه وفي هذه الاجواء من العواصف
المحيطه بحكومه نتنياهو
ياول نائب رئيس الاركان السابق من ب جانس
عضو مجلس الحرب بالعمل على اسقاط حكومه
نتنياهو عبر الاستقاله منها فهي لن تسقط
طالما بقي فيها في حين نقلت صحيفتها ارس
عن اعضاء في المجلس الوزاري المصغر قولهم
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يحقق حتى الان اي
من اهداف الحرب في
غزه المعارك المحتد في القطاع تظهر للشارع
الاسرائيلي كما للمسؤولين ما يبدو قدرا من
التباين بين ما يعلنه التقييم العسكري
اليومي وما تكشف عنه كتائب القسام من
قدرات اضافه الى ان اغلبيه الانفاق تبدو
فعاله ولم تهدم
بعد تطورات تشي بان المعركه التي كان
يعتقد انها ستندلع في اليوم التالي
لانتهاء الحرب بشان من يتحملوا مسؤوليه
الاخفاق في السابع من اكتوبر الجيش ام
الحكومه قد استعرت مبكرا لا سما في ظل
الاعداد المتزايده المعلن عنها لقتل الجيش
الاسرائيلي في غزه والاقرار المتواتر بان
المعارك معقده وتتطلب وقتا يتجاهل نتنياهو
الرد على مهاجميه في الحكومه والشارع
ويكتفي بالحديث عن ضروره توحيد الصفوف
ووضع الخلافات جانبا من اجل تحقيق اهداف
الحرب حرب يقول مسؤولون في الجيش انهم لا
يعرفون حتى الان
ماها a